so i can just do this
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
being the god who showed up throughout
all of that
who
wove it together with grace and peace
and community
guide our hearts into this next year of
finding you finding
connection and community support with
others
um would you would you meet us
in this space and guide us and um
give us a piece of not knowing
the instructions or even how to read the
instructions but trusting and having
hope in a god that
already knows what is before us
um
yeah and that you're going to meet us
there and draw us together and that hope
is ours peace is ours grace is ours
because of you because of jesus
um
i pray all these things in your son's
most precious name amen
amen
thanks kelly if you guys want to stand
with us we're going to get started um
gary's going to lead this first song
i hope you guys will warm up as we sing
feel free to clap dance jump around
anything to get the blood pumping and if
you're one of the crazy people that
walked in in shorts i'm praying for you
okay
it's a special place in my heart for
people like you
cool hey um just want to acknowledge i
don't know what it is but i feel a
little nervous today i've done this a
thousand times but
man it still happens so
um
yeah
and i also just want to say
that this song again i did this a few
weeks ago
um that there is no shame here whatever
you brought in here with you today man
leave it at the door yeah you know
so yeah let's sing together
and
praise our god
[Music]
sometimes on this journey
get lost in my mistakes
it looks to me like weakness
my story isn't over
my story's just begun
failure won't define me
that's what my father does
fear you won't you find me
check your
[Music]
house
oh
[Music]
house
articles come home
help us
[Music]
love is
take
[Music]
place in the room
now we're
shaking through
when the father's in the room
[Music]
no shame here
yes
so
[Music]
before
and you make all things
work together
for my future
and for
my good
you make all things
work together
for my glory
and for your name
there's a healing
[Music]
work together
for my future
and for my good to make all things
work together
your glory
and for your name and to make all
things work together
for my future
and for my good if you make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name
[Music]
and the clay because i know nothing has
been wasted
no failure no mistake
you're an artist and a potter behind the
canvas and the clay that you make all
things
[Music]
work together
for my future
[Music]
and for my good
me
[Music]
you're not finished with me yet but
you're not finished
[Music]
you're not finished with me yet
when i doubt it lord remind me
i'm wonderfully made
you're an artist
your request in the comments
[Music]
you
for the old and the sick
for the widow and
[Music]
to the love
how can i respond
to the love that
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't have
a much
[Music]
every part of me
me
[Music]
i have
that means for you i have a heart now
[Music]
wherever we feel like we're lacking god
whatever sickness whatever struggle
[Music]
whatever brokenness we carry with us god
whatever pain or loss we've experienced
in this past year
we acknowledge those
we see them for what they are
and then we look to you
believing that you can do immeasurably
more than we think or ask or imagine
that you are the god of redemption
you are the god of comfort
you are the god of grace and forgiveness
[Music]
others god
and
would we know that you will carry us
through
[Music]
and would you do what only you can do
god and take the very little that we
have and fill it to overflowing with
your love
we look to you this year
we invite you into it
we thank you for what's ahead
both the good and the bad because we
know that you will be there with us
through it all
[Music]
thank you for this community god
thank you for support and love
would we find you in the midst of it
it's in your name i ask all these things
thank you jesus
[Music]
thank you amen
y'all can go ahead and be seated and
would you turn to the people around you
and say hello
here and it's just wonderful to be with
you all thank you for being here
on a chilly chilly evening
so this is um well i want to before i
keep going i want to um also give a warm
welcome to those join us online we love
you lots i know there's a more than
usual tonight lots of text from people
saying join us online um and uh and i
also want to give a warm welcome to
everyone who's uh new
thank you so much for being here i know
it can take you know just some courage
to walk through those doors and come
into a new place and a new people and
you know all that so uh thank you for
being with us
um so we this is a really special night
because at the the very first sunday of
the year um we uh always um do what we
call story sunday and it's basically
where we have a few folks um
who share the story of kind of what they
their journey the last sometimes it's
year sometimes it's even extends beyond
that if it's been kind of a you know an
ongoing theme um and
we um
you know kind of one of our assumptions
here is that um god is with us
and that christ is present
and that he is doing a good work in
our lives he's up to something
and
there's a passage it's from john
chapter 15
verses 6 through 27
um it's jesus
speaking he says when the advocate comes
whom i will send you from the father the
spirit of truth who goes out from the
father he will testify about me and you
also must testify for you have been with
me from the beginning
and i love that verse because it's such
a beautiful description of how
this holy spirit is present to each one
of us i don't think there's like anyone
in the world
that is somehow absent
you know but like the spirit is present
and especially as like followers of
christ like of course the spirit is
present to us since then christ is
present for the spirit and he's doing
that good thing in our life and
um
and so tonight to kind of hear from a
few folks who get to share about the
something that god has been up to um now
that doesn't mean it's always like a
neat and tidy little story that's like
well i used to have challenges in my
life but now all that's over and done
with
you know um just onward upward um it's
messy right like cause life is messy um
we're just human beings
and yes god's doing a good thing but it
that doesn't mean like the process is
all like smooth and easy um it can be
really really messy and at times in ways
unresolved you know so
um just know that the folks um that we
have sharing tonight i've given them
full permission to be themselves to be
where they're at they don't have to like
pretend to have i don't know like more
faith than they actually maybe really
have or um
to even make it more neat and tidy you
know than it really um was or is even
now so um all that to say i do think
there will be things you can
kind of glean because
at the end of the day like god is god is
present christ is present to to them and
in us so i hope you are able to glean
something beautiful um from their
stories so uh with that in mind i want
to invite brittany johnson up y'all give
her a hand
she comes up
[Applause]
brittany grab that mic
your favorite you love being in front of
people with a microphone
um brittany britty and i we've been
friends for a very long time and um
something i really appreciate about
brittany well a few things one is she is
very attuned to other people and their
their needs
um just very like sensitive and
thoughtful
and that will actually i think play out
some in her story later um
but i do love that about her and i also
um i love that she is like a laid-back
person i am not a laid-back person and
so i really respect people who can like
be in the midst of chaos and it's like
it's okay
and i mean this is why i think maybe
she's graced to help lead our kids
ministry um the lord knows there can be
some chaos back there um so all to say
thank you brittany i know they are being
quiet yeah maybe they're treating you
well yeah
um so
brittany can you kind of um tell us a
little bit about yourself a little
background for those who maybe don't
know you whether it's you know where you
live family situation how you found the
table you know all that stuff
okay um i'm brittany i'm married to
scott who is usually in the sound booth
he's not tonight
we live in rowlett we have three
children
l is
in sixth grade
lorelei is in
fourth grade and trace is in second
grade
um
and we
like brett said we've been friends with
brett and maggie for a really long time
it's been 14 years and a few years ago
they asked us to be on the launch team
for
a church and
of course we knew if they were going we
were going with them there wasn't really
brett did ask us to take some time to
think about it and pray about it but we
already knew our answer
um and then
while we were at that church i took over
the kids ministry there after about a
year and then when he asked us to launch
the table of course we said yes
so that's how we're here
um
and yeah i think that's it yeah
so um
so you have um
well you've been through like a whole
kind of process the last few it's really
been years plural right like not just
the last you know six months or a year
right um it's been been quite a thing
and um
like i mentioned you're naturally pretty
attuned to people you're attuned to
their needs and i kind of think of you
as like very much a glue person for
those who are familiar with the
enneagram um she's enneagram 9.
so
you know kind of the peacemaker you know
it's like the person who can we're going
to stay together people and
i'll i'll contort myself into whatever
pretzel i have to to make this work
and that's kind of brittany um so but
but through doing that it kind of um
well you started to realize that that's
maybe
that can sound really good and like well
what a good person you are but it's not
always kind of healthy um
so catch us up a little bit on
you know kind of some of the process
you've been through and how did you
start to realize like oh
maybe this is leading me to operate in
ways that aren't always like healthy
right
okay so like brett said i am a nine and
we are called the peacemaker and when
most people think of a peacemaker they
think of someone who is like a mediator
or
just wants everybody to get along
and that is true but
it's a little more complicated than that
and it gets unhealthy because while i
will like with the people i trust i will
dive into conflict i'll press into it
i'll work through it i don't want to be
in conflict and if there is conflict i
don't run away from it but i will do
everything i can to avoid that conflict
ever coming up so in a lot of ways that
means that i'm losing myself and i'm i'm
in a very unhealthy place because i'm
going to go to great lengths to make
sure that everything is peaceful
yeah and i'll talk more about it yeah
when wait so when did you realize
this like was this is a thing like i've
got some issues here and i'm
kind of uh like the way you put it was
i'm doing everything i can to make sure
we avoid the conflict happening like so
when did this start to come on your
radar as like oh this is a
real challenge for me
i'm gonna go back a little bit um to
college i was a psychology major
and
in almost every class we talked about
codependency and but i remember the
first time we talked about it
it made me very uncomfortable but i
realized it was because it felt so
familiar
and
when you're in when you're in college
and taking all these psychology classes
the first thing every professor will
tell you is not to read into everything
that you're learning and because you're
going to see yourself in everything and
so i was able to dismiss it like oh
that's not me you know it just feels
that way because i'm you know like
everybody else i see myself and
everything so
um
but that's really when like this the
seed of like this is a struggle for me
was planted but
um then you know you're fast forward to
just a couple of years ago i had a
really
big falling out with my best friend and
um
it was then
i started going to therapy and realized
this hurts so much because i was in a
codependent relationship and it was very
unhealthy
and i mean it was i had a lot of
depression had a lot of anxiety i was i
i couldn't
fully function i mean i was doing the
things i was supposed to do i was taking
care of my kids i was going to work i
was showing up
but i wasn't
i wasn't all there i wasn't fully
functioning so that's really when
i started to realize this is
something i need to work on yeah what
can you describe a little bit like what
was that season like for you i mean
obviously it wasn't it doesn't sound
like it was good
but um
what yeah i don't know like what were
you experiencing what emotions were you
experiencing
i don't know what was this i think
i think most of it was anxiety
um i mean that led to
moments of depression but i think most
of it was anxiety because my world had
just crumbled
and i didn't know how to pick up those
pieces and i didn't know how to move
forward
yeah when you say why world
well because when you're in a
co-dependent relationship
that's your world yeah
yeah so it's it
so for you it wasn't as simple as like i
have this one valuable relationship and
oh no that's kind of disintegrating
right it was like
it's it's kind of all-consuming um so
i didn't
even at that point i didn't really
understand that that's what was going on
it wasn't until
i started therapy
and um
i knew
like
that it had been a few years i knew i
needed therapy i needed to go to therapy
for other things and just because
everybody needs therapy but
um
my scott and i had prioritized marriage
counseling and we couldn't afford for
both of us to be in therapy and marriage
counsel it gets expensive so
um
finally at this point we were like no i
really need to do this i need to
i need to process through this with
someone who can help me you know figure
out and get get my bearings again so
i started therapy and
um
i started like as i'm processing with
her i started going through all the
things like everything that would come
up
that we would talk about
happening and like you know even talking
to her about
the relationship and how
we existed in that relationship
eventually it got to a point where i
could say
oh this was a codependent relationship
and for me what that looked like was
um like i said like i lost myself
in this person
but for me it was
because i am i'm very empathetic and i
can feel what everybody's feeling and
side note we lived together our families
cohabitated together so it was even like
more dysfunctional than just we were
best friends in a co-dependent
relationship
but
if i felt like she was stressed out
about something
i took it from her i took that thing
whatever it was it could have been
something big it could have been
um doing laundry cooking dinner like i
did it because
in that moment
it kept the peace
things were peaceful and i enjoyed doing
those things so
it wasn't hard for me to do those things
but i the reason i was doing it was
because i didn't want her to feel
stressed
and anytime she felt anxious i would do
everything i could to alleviate that
anxiety even if it meant i was more
anxious because of it
and so
um that was
that was one one of the things that was
like uh red flag hello um
and in the midst of that like
even those things you know our friends
would would make comments about me doing
all of it and i would just brush it off
and say but i love doing it like i
really i really do love
cleaning and cooking
and doing laundry so it wasn't a big
deal for me to do it you think she's
joking but
there's i mean
you do i do i really love it um it's
kind of therapeutic for me it's like
getting rid of all the
dirtiness yeah so why was it bad then um
well it was bad because on one hand i
was taking away her ability to do things
um i was taking away her not power but
you know like
i was taking away her
adultness and humanness and
i was
allowing her
to be dependent on me and it was just
creating this very unhealthy i mean she
wasn't a child she didn't need me to do
her laundry or
cook every meal or you know whatever it
was and so it was taking away
this like ownership for her and at the
same time
taking away energy from me
and
creating this constant
pattern of
tension building and anxiety and then
there would be
an explosion in our friendship and i
mean even before the major falling out
there was this pattern of that and
so it was just unhealthy i mean it just
wasn't it's not a healthy way to live so
yeah
the other thing the other red flag about
i mean like one of the things i was able
to pinpoint
was that
i had this separation anxiety which you
think of like a toddler being separated
from their parents it was basically like
that not so much like when she would go
to work or
you know doing everyday things but going
on family vacations like i didn't want
to go without them i didn't want to do
celebrate special occasions without them
even just going over to friends houses
and hanging out there was always this
like anxiety about it and
in the midst of that i knew that that
was a struggle i didn't know though that
it was a bigger
it was a symptom of a bigger problem i
didn't realize that so
yeah
one thing i
really appreciate even as we process
this this topic some before
um tonight
is i appreciate how
you're able to own this because i think
in hearing it it might be easy to like
hear about the other person and kind of
blame and just like well how dare they
let me become codependent with them in
this way
um versus you kind of owning like well
so much about like them
right this this was in no way
her fault
i
i had no boundaries in the relationship
and boundaries are something that i
struggle with in all of my relationships
including like with my children but um
i just i don't have boundaries people
have told me that i'm not very
approachable or that i come across a
snobby
but once you're my friend i will do
everything i'll be whoever like brett
said i'll be whoever i need to be to
make our friendship peaceful and to be
chosen that that's the word that i kept
like
that kept coming up as i was getting
ready for this is to be chosen
wow that's a powerful word yeah
and i suspect resonates with
if you heard the collective um you know
um because i think there is something
like in all of us
you know that wants that but then how
does it manifest you know how who do we
become so that we're chosen and for some
people it's totally different you know
some people become like achievers i'm
going to win everything you know but for
you it played out in this
you know this way
wow
um
how about um
just other like key relationships in
your life you know did this play out in
other places or ways i mean
it has i
um i as i was actually as i was getting
ready for this i
um
realized
i think
it did and when i was dating scott the
separation part the separation anxiety
it hadn't really clicked for me but
when we were dating that was a really
hard thing for me i mean totally changed
when we got married i think you know
like once we were married i knew well
okay fine he's mine i don't have to
worry about that anymore um
but
for sure there
and it's
there
there's
different parts of it that i struggle
with in all of my relationship but i
think the biggest one is losing myself
and
i mean to the point that like
i will i mean this is kind of a nine
thing too but
um
my thoughts my opinions my feelings i
will adopt everybody else's
like i i struggle having my own i need
approval from people to make decisions
like all of that is a struggle for me
and there's not i mean
i don't think there's any other
relationship that i have struggled with
codependency
as much as that one but
there's definitely little pieces of it
everywhere yeah
so like we mentioned um
this is you know hasn't just been
something you've had a realization like
two weeks ago or something like this has
been sort of years that you realize like
oh wow okay i need to start functioning
in some new ways so could you share
i guess a little bit of like
you know whatever language you want to
use but you know what has has god taught
you
what
how have you grown into operating in
you know less or non codependent ways
you're like what has that part of it
been like and you know
um
yeah what have you learned basically
about how to do it like better yeah
um well i am in no way an expert
i'm still learning and still practicing
this
and it still scares me but
i mean i'm gonna say it over and over
again but therapy was the biggest thing
and really
the reason why is because i was able to
speak
really hard truths about myself to
someone and say them out loud and it was
a safe space i knew there would be no
judgment i knew she wasn't going to be
shocked you know and
until you can say those hard things out
loud you can't do anything about them
they can be ideas all day long but
you know it wasn't until i was able to
say them to her
and she was able to
you know just like she couldn't like
grab me in her arms because it was
through tv but it's just like that warm
hug you know like it's okay we're gonna
get through this we're gonna work
through it and
um
the first
i have a few things that i was going to
talk about the first one was boundaries
and i've already talked about this but
this was
the biggest thing and not like i went to
my friends and i said you know this is a
boundary if you cross it
that's it like you know it wasn't like
that i didn't go talk to my friends
about these boundaries
but it was boundaries that i set for
myself because
i mean it was codependency so um
it was me it was i was the one who
needed the boundaries for myself and
um
they were little boundaries along the
way like every week i think there was
probably a new boundary i was working on
creating for myself i did i do have a
couple of examples one of them was um
just
and this one was
i was able to practice it in my marriage
but this was one that i struggled with a
lot with her
but i also struggled with it with scott
and um
but it's
taking
everything personally like
his actions
they're not mine
and separating myself from that just
like her actions were not mine if she
did something i didn't have to own it i
could separate myself from that but
i would i would try to fix it because i
i took it so personally and so
i've been able to work on that with
scott like in my relationship with scott
and not like letting his actions be his
and i don't have to try to fix it or
make excuses for it or you know whatever
like
they're his
um and then the other
one was my own time and while i am like
i do love doing things for people um and
i really do
and i you know but
making sure that i'm not using all my
energy on everybody else and then i'm
taking time
for myself
because i can't
because i'm an introvert too i can't
i can't give from an empty cup you know
like i i have to take time for myself so
yeah
amazing thank you thank you so much for
i i think this topic in particular
especially in a christian context we're
always emphasizing like love others be
there for them
empathize
you know and that's true
yes do that and yet there is some line
of like but i'm like not
you
you know and i can't literally like take
everything you know like there's some
kind of invisible berry that we kind of
cross and all of a sudden it's not
healthy for us or them right and i just
i think it's incredibly insightful the
journey you've been on so thanks thank
you you'll give her a hand
[Applause]
all right
um next is
my
good friend will humble
come on up you'll give him a hand as he
comes
[Applause]
so my first um interaction like at least
like face-to-face interaction with will
was um
uh probably it was a while ago well over
a year ago but we went to the 1418
coffee shop in plano and got to hang out
and um something that immediately stood
out to me about will was that he
um was incredibly like
straightforward
and honest i don't know if you've had
some interactions with will but
like he's gonna tell you the truth you
know and i really appreciate that uh
about you will and uh if you don't know
him i hope you get a chance to to meet
him and he is a little bit nervous
tonight more than a little bit
but um but you have our love
you have our love and our support
so thank you for sharing tonight
um so really in order to um
well maybe i guess first share a little
bit just you know who you are how you
found the table
kids you know some of that info
my name is william
henry umbel iii
will humble
so there's a bible verse second
chronicles 7 14 in the niv version
that's important
god says that he will hear from heaven
he will forgive your sin and heal
if my people who are called by my name
will
humble
themselves and pray and seek my face and
turn from their wicked ways will
humble
you know matthew mark luke and john
those are bible names
i have a bible name
so i grew up in a tiny tiny texas town
one walmart
two sisters no brothers
since 2002
to earn a living
i've been doing fbi work
with aliens
aliens as in non-citizens so fbi just
stands for family based immigration fbi
i also do employment-based immigration
and asylum and citizenship and other
stuff it's never a dull moment
in 2017
i moved to plano texas
i'm divorced i have four kids ages three
five seven and fourteen
they live in wiley texas with their mom
and with their uncle
who is gay
he is my ex-brother
so we may not be brother-in-law's
anymore but he'll always be their uncle
i found the table this church because i
googled
gay affirming churches near me
and a website popped up called
gaychurch.org
and then there was this list
so i went down the list i just started
visiting lots and lots and lots of
different churches
not fun
but
good good for me there was one
greenland hills methodist church in
dallas is where i met pastor carrie
smith
who introduced me to
pastor gary fox
who introduced me to don jacobs
have you all heard of dawn
well here i am
connect the dots
yeah so that's how i made it here cool
so in order to understand your story um
it's really important i think to kind of
know your church
you know background since it um like you
did not grow up a nominal church
attender you know christor christmas
easter attendant like no no your family
like y'all were
in
and um
and that whole culture it really
powerfully you know influenced
you so can you talk to us a little bit
about
that experience how it shaped to you
know in many ways um you were
and maybe to some degree are but but
primarily were
my church background
i called it super baptist
have you heard of bill gothard
um no card playing
no smoking
no drinking no dancing no rock music
not even christian rock because that has
a syncopated beat
the devil's beat
no tv
no
not homeschooling a mentor actually said
out loud that a christian who sends his
kids to public school is sinning
no dating
no premarital eye contact
i literally never gave a compliment
because that might lead her heart astray
as a male i was obligated to never tempt
a female if she were to develop a crush
that would be my sin
no birth control
children are a blessing children are a
blessing
my
this worldview prized huge families
duggar huge
um my ex-wife is one of nine children
so i thought i was gonna sire even more
than that
you take over the world your way i'll
take over the world my way
no divorce
so yeah it it influenced me in every in
every way but i thought i was happy and
my i was happy i embraced this whole
world view i happily followed that
blueprint i did not date i courted
and even when i was
courting my then fiance we agreed i was
happy with this it was even her request
no kissing we will not kiss until the
minister says you may now kiss the bride
i didn't know any different so i thought
this was all good and normal well
abnormal
but in a good way
it was special
extraordinary
i was even arrogant knowing that i was
in
and all y'all sinners were out
so this exclusive world view influenced
all of my actions and all of my
attitudes i was frankly a
holier-than-thou judgmental jerk
like i said straightforward
yeah
um
so
what happened you know like how do you
go from that kind of background that
world
and then
you're
searching you know gay churches near me
you know like how
yeah what what were some of the events
or things that led you to a place of
like kind of crisis and like okay wow i
can't keep doing that that thing you
know
my world view
failed when my marriage failed
my church friends
weren't friends anymore
nobody called me
now in their defense
i didn't call them either so i guess the
phone works both ways
but still a friendship like that is
worthless
this whole experience was
heartbreaking
and while my divorce was pending i was
diagnosed with cancer
i went through surgery
radiation
chemotherapy
all that physical pain gave me
perspective
so now i have sympathy and so much
appreciation
my father was the only person in my life
so i thank god for him
i
i never hated god i never felt like god
left me but all of the adults in my life
disappeared
zero
so i can't kind of hated
everybody else so
um and that sent me searching
this was a death of my past the death of
my marriage the death of the old me
all of that sent me searching and i was
mourning the
death of the old me i literally
sat in my car crying calling suicide
prevention hotline but even that felt
totally pathetic
because i wasn't serious about suicide
and so i would apologize to these
hotline workers for wasting their time
but that was a safe person to talk to
who else you gonna talk to someone from
your old world
no
um
so there were some defining moments in
this um
change
may 13
of 2019 i stumbled across a book called
god
believes in love
great book
this guy mr robinson
it was like the
gas in the engine that
fueled my
180 degree turn
and then in june of 2019 that's when the
family court judge in collin county
signed the divorce so that was the end
of an old chapter in my life and i
decided to take that defining moment as
a
new chapter i opened my mind to a whole
new
world view
now that i was no longer in the box of
marriage so to speak
i've been legally set free
now what maybe maybe i could start
asking questions before i wasn't even
allowed to ask the question much less
answer the question what about me
what do i really feel
about everything life death sexual
orientation i
let myself
ask questions and start answering them
and stop lying
july 3rd coincidentally it's the day
before independence day
i had my first
spiritual direction session like like
counseling sort of but with the pastor
and it was over the phone he was in
california matt nightingale was his name
he was the first person that i'd ever
encountered that was anything like me he
used to be married had four kids now
he's divorced
he's gay and he doesn't hate god and he
still goes to church
that just blew my mind
and then
august was the first time i met somebody
face to face that was pastor gary fox
somebody like me i'm not the only one
so that was a huge stepping stone
in this
world tour my
worldview 180 degree turn tour
change
those were big steps yeah
yeah
um
big steps that's like these are some
huge transitions can you
share with us a little bit like
so
like how would you describe where you
are now
you know so like you've had you start
off in this place
you have the divorce you have these
huge upheavals and it's like you
mentioned this you know uh the 180
degree turn
and then
you know but it's been a while kind of
like brittany and all this didn't happen
two weeks ago like you're talking some
of the dates you know
you know so you've you've had some time
to process this how would you describe
like where you know kind of where you
are now like some of the changes you've
made you know things like that old will
would say
that the idea that you're born this way
is no excuse if you're born a
kleptomaniac you have to suppress those
urges pray the steal away
but now
new will now will
sees it more like being left-handed i'm
not gonna pray my left away
by the way do you know why left-handed
people will never sit on the right hand
of god
no
because they would bump elbows
sorry dad joke
but now today i wear three hats i have
my go to work hat it fits good my
co-workers my clients the paperwork the
people work it's all good
then every other weekend and two nights
a week with my kids that hat fits good
it's all candy and cartoons we're in a
good
routine and i think little by little
you know i remind them to say please and
thank you it's developmental it's it's
good it's my circus
the third hat is like here now this is
so uncomfortable
this is so weird and out of my comfort
zone and trying to find people who don't
hate god but who are open-minded and
inclusive not exclusive
but it still hurts
i don't feel safe talking to people and
um
i guess if if you're comfortable you're
not growing so
being
growing means you're uncomfortable so
uncomfortable is good
um
a really good thing about all this is
the freedom i finally have some freedom
from shame freedom from lying and hiding
freedom to
freedom from fear-based religion
and honesty i can quit lying to myself
and quit looking at the bible through a
a lens of misinterpretation that is
based on flawed
translations
what has been hard
after a lifetime of lying to myself and
others it is hard to take off that mask
it is just automatic to say everything
is fine and smile
um
did you already ask me how the table has
been helpful
i haven't but go for it
unless it hasn't been
then we can just move on i said i would
i couldn't do this if i didn't have the
questions in advance and one of the
questions he gave me was how has the
table
or has the table has is there a way
anyway the table has been helpful
in this journey
yes the table has helped me feel not
alone and
to have a safe place to talk i've been
going to a small group where i met abby
and katie and they told me about a book
called love wins
wow
i didn't even know there was another
layer
to the cult that i grew up in
um
that's another area where my past
influenced all my actions and attitudes
even when i was a kindergartner i asked
jesus into my heart based on fear
this idea of
permanent conscious torture
so i asked jesus into my heart because i
was terrified of hell
now that cheap level of faith did grow i
didn't it wasn't just that as a teenager
you know i
had faith and love god and it's real
um
but to get away from this idea that it's
all about escaping hell is another
mind-blowing freedom
but what about that question so am i
saying it doesn't matter who you pray to
because we're all going to the same
heaven anyway jesus doesn't matter
jesus does matter he is the why and how
of heaven even now here on earth
and here at the table i can talk about
those kinds of things without being a
heretic or heresy or getting shunned
from my cult
so i'm learning that hell quote unquote
isn't necessarily a destination period
it's a process with a refining purpose
and i want my kids to learn that too i
don't want them to always think
do this don't do that or you'll go to
hell you're going to hell they're going
to hell
i want them to know that god's love
isn't exclusive it's inclusive it's
unconditional
i'm so proud of my kids because they
even told me hey santa claus isn't that
conditional love
yes let's have some joy and peace and
kindness
what um
what would the
the will of today like what maybe word
phrase advice input what would you tell
the will of the past
don't
bother with dr weiss his materials were
aimed at how to stay in an unfaithful
marriage and that
was not a right fit
don't don't listen to so-called
christian counselors
snapping rubber bands every time you
have a left-handed thought
no
don't lose hope it gets it does get
better
do question old ways it's okay to have
doubt it's okay to
ask why and why not and keep asking
ask for help
don't wait for people to be mind readers
know to ask you have to initiate
so take the initiative
there's another verse i want to share
romans
6 6-7 for we know that our old self
was crucified with him so that the body
ruled by sin
might be done away with that we should
no longer be slaves to sin
anyone who has died has been set free
from sin
we're set free so let's live already
yeah
that's that's incredibly beautiful i can
see like just getting to know you the
past year especially i can see you just
stepping more and more into that freedom
i remember we had the uh
october because halloween fell on a
sunday this year so we did our you know
outdoor kind of uh trunk or treat event
and
and there was will you know with your
station and you were setting it all up
and
i was like how are you and you were just
like i'm great and you could see like a
like a joy and you were i mean in light
of your background i can tell like why
that's such a big deal for you i'm
guessing halloween wasn't like on the
thumbs up list probably of the past you
know
um
and but it's you just learning to like
relax a little bit and
love
people
and experience joy and that it's it's
really incredible to watch so thank you
for making the journey and
and for us having a chance to like
witness it it's really beautiful we're
grateful
thank you well thanks yes y'all give him
a hand
good stuff
good stuff that's the um the something
that god is up to
you know in each of us
so as we kind of come into this year
um
i want us all to be kind of reflecting
and looking backwards but also looking
ahead to say like okay god what do you
have for me how am i
being stretched how am i growing what's
the thing god's doing
and to press into that
because it matters like it doesn't just
matter for you and your family or your
friends but even like us as a community
and it ripples out you know i mean a
brittany
will like those changes and
transformations that's rippling out into
their whole life
and so it it matters so let it encourage
us to um love christ and move forward as
well let me pray for you lord jesus i um
i just thank you for the good work that
you're doing in brittany's life in
will's life
and the ripple effects that are
happening in and through them and
for all of us god you're up to something
beautiful
in each and every one of us so
right now god we just um
we open up our hearts our minds to what
you're up to
in our life this year and we even now
say yes to it god
knowing it will be challenging knowing
there will be times where we feel
despair and feel like giving up and yet
we trust that you're present we trust
that you're with us that your spirit is
filling us and
you are forming us into the very image
of the lord jesus christ that's a
beautiful work
so we love you god
it's in the powerful wonderful
life-giving
name of jesus christ that i pray
amen
i love story sunday so much it's like
i look forward to it
all year long
um
and we're gonna close with the song i
raise a hallelujah and i feel like it's
just like
let this be our anthem like coming off
of those stories it just feels so
empowering to
like face our hard truths to embrace the
hard work that we have to do to grow
and believe that um jesus is doing a
good thing among us and in us as we do
it so you guys stand up with us for this
last one and uh i wish i could stand up
and play the drums at the same time
because i feel like it's wrong to sit
down during the song but you guys just
stand for me okay
[Music]
of my enemies
i raise a hallelujah
[Music]
louder than the unbelief
my weapon is a melody
our razor hallelujah
[Music]
comes to fight for me
is
[Music]
[Applause]
i will watch the darkness
hallelujah
[Music]
death is defeated
is
[Music]
sing a little louder
sing a little
[Music]
presence louder my enemies
louder and louder
[Music]
is
hallelujah
[Music]
um
this is
[Music]
a little cheesy
a visitor tonight
welcome i am so so genuinely glad you're
here as you're leaving the building
there's a little box where you can fill
out a card and give us some information
so we can connect with you and hear your
instructions
for life and if you are interested in a
meetup group we have these groups that
meet and they are so precious and it's a
support group a group for encouragement
a safe place to land in the middle of
your week i highly encourage reaching
out and being
a part of a meetup group and you can
also
fill out a little sheet out there if you
were interested in that
next week our 7th through 12th graders
will be meeting right after the service
so you are also invited to do that
if you regularly attend the table or you
call the table home we invite you to
give
not just of yourselves or of prayer or
showing up but in a monetary way to help
keep this train moving because gas costs
money
so
thank you
thank you for doing that and i encourage
you to show up in that way if you're
able and
i looked up different new year
benedictions because i really love words
i love poems i love
the painting that words can do so i
found this really beautiful one that i
wanted to share with you guys before we
send you on your way into 2022 and it's
by a woman named sandy messick
if you would like to join in a posture
of closing your eyes raising your hands
sitting down and just breathing deep
before we enter into this week
i invite you to do whatever feels right
for you in this moment
[Music]
god of all times and seasons on this
threshold of a new year we turn and
return again to you
the year spreads before us with
possibilities and challenges joys and
concerns there is beauty all around in
the smiles of children and the love
offered between friends and the beauty
of the earth
but there are also challenges already
surfacing in the closing days of last
year we have seen the images of war-torn
countries terrorist attacks hunger
poverty and despair
your heart grieves when your children
anywhere hurting in our hearts grief too
then again we know that even in the
midst of winter there is hope for spring
and even in the midst of greece there
are signs of hope
children embrace
lives touched by grace heroes who
surface in times of trial in the midst
of the good and the bad hear our prayer
for this new year
god help us to love a bit more deeply
see the beauty around us more clearly
listen more earnestly
speak more honestly may we be troubled
by injustice and be moved to act may we
be led by compassion and be moved to
serve
may we walk softly upon this earth and
be gentle towards your creation
may we be courageous and bold witnesses
for you
may we be a living example of your
gracious love not only in a word
but by deed and may we daily give thanks
for the others in our lives and in the
world that do the same and more every
day in innumerable ways
for the promise in this new year we give
you thanks
help us to live it wisely and well
in jesus name amen
peace be with you happy new year
[Music]
so i realized
you